and j half on the mound gets a start for
the twins
here are his starting pitcher stats you
can see the era is good
whip not too bad and he's been really
good with
runners in scoring position let's hope
he keeps all of that going
announce a full count to reynolds with
moran on deck
gromball the third charging is donaldson
on the run fields and throws him out
good play by donaldson
so happ works a one two three first
inning we have played one half at target
field
the twins are gonna face jt brubacher
who's looked awfully good so far for the
bucks
yes he has when hitting lead off erise
has an on base percentage of 524
and he can do that too off the end of
the glove of adam frazier he's pretty
good
feeling second baseman he may have
mistimed his jump there
a little bit it's a base head for
arrives well just another great
two-strike approach from
luis horiz not jumping out too soon
waiting for the ball to travel a little
bit so they can recognize that breaking
ball and it
settled right into his happy zone so
here is
nelson cruz oh
look at this no no no says nelson cruz
not happy with jose navas the home plate
umpire
keep it up get him tossed come on yes
please get out of here say something
and he's still in the game okay so after
one it is nothing nothing
from target field as you take a look i
mean it's just a beauty i mean right on
the edge songs catches it
gets around it beautiful this is the
only inter-league game
in the major leagues this weekend
shattered bat
and austin deal covers his head then
goes to the bag
wow the barrel of the bat ended up
almost into right field
those feel nice you remember what those
feel like don't you oh man
that's that's deep in the kitchen right
there real good fastball
i have right underneath the hands of
colin moran
hasta deal had good focus on the
baseball he knew the bat was somewhere
in the vicinity
stayed on the baseball and covered up
his head okay now i'm okay i can run to
the base
here's osta deal dostodio hitting 286 no
homers he's knocked in five
walla to left field and gone a home run
ostenio's first of the year and the
twins take the first lead
the one guy that wouldn't be impressed
with the fact that the guy's got a good
fastball and he might throw me a slider
willie was asked to deal throw me a high
fastball
swinging anyway he just clubbed him
tried to go up stairs and he just
clubbed it
and half out there to start the fourth
inning brian reynold
cave is there and the first down to the
fourth on two pitches it'll bring up
colin moran
got him 91 mile per hour fastball enough
to beat moran and out number two
a little a little extra carry on that in
a really good spot
up and in i mean that will get most
left-handers out right there
that pitch right there to a left-hander
there aren't too many
that that will hit it eric gonzalez drew
a walk with one out in the second
that's to left field carol off getting a
chance every inning
he makes the play half has now set down
seven men
in a row
and a pitch and crews with a sharp
single lap
put the barrel on it and is in at first
base with a one out single
got a fastball middle middle and
brubacher's lucky that didn't end up
about 40 rolls past where ostadio hit
his
here's buxton there's a chopper right
side good luck
and that's what i mean about the
maturation of byron he with two strikes
he's got an approach now
we saw him get a base hit in wednesday's
game
similar to that with two strikes he's my
favorite at bat of the hole
he clubbed home runs all over the field
tough slider with two
strikes that's a strikeout for him up
until this year
now no chance you said no chance
just put the ball in play get somehow
and get that speed and that's what he
has that very few people have
so polanco it is one ball one strike on
jorge
the ground ball to frazier so tip your
cap to jt
brubacher he uh battled
and kept the twins off the board we'll
see what the twins can do to add to a
one-nothing lead
a high fly to left field off the bat of
cave evans going back
and cave has it go out it's a home run
to the opposite field just the second
home run hit by a left-handed matter
this year
and he goes oppo to get it he's got that
kind of power we've seen him go
way back when he barrels it up and he
can hit the ball out anywhere this was a
this was a pretty swing right here just
hitting back
through the ball powered that ball over
the fence
no hits allowed 75 pitches so far for
half guys
and he's nine outs away from making
history
and it'll be brian reynolds leading off
the seventh against happ
that's the ball flared to right field
cave is there one away
and that'll bring up moran got him
looking two down
just buzzed the fastball on the outside
part of the plate not exactly on the
corner but
there's a good look at his four seam
grip twins by two seventh inning two
outs
to left field carol off is there
and that's out number three happ has a
no hitter through
seven he's been excellent
hadn't completed five innings yet this
year with about the same number of
pitches
now in the hole polanco firing on the
road one away
the twins have had five no-hitters in
their
61-year history most recently francisco
liriano
nearly 10 years ago what a terrific play
this was by the shortstop
the second baseman playing shortstop
again and now
two strikes on stallings full count
line drive and there it is jacob
stallings
of course breaks up the no hit bid with
a
double the left field he wrapped it down
the left field line
and again keep in mind this game is far
from over
as hap will get the traditional standing
ovation
and now the question is how long does
rocco buldelli stay
with the 38 year old veteran wow
jacob stallings a no doubt double
quite a night for jhab just his third
start as a twin
and he was brilliant taylor rogers comes
into the ball game he
had one of the best outings of his
career in the loss wednesday in oakland
twins by two
ninth inning bases empty two outs moran
back in the batter's box
rogers looks into garber has his sign
got it wednesday 12 runs weren't enough
tonight two are enough and the twins
open this brief home stand
with a two-nothing win